going through this album and listening
to you talk about this album you seem
like a man with purpose and perspective
and I think I am thank you yeah yes talk
to me talk me through that where was
your head at and where was your heart at
when you wanted to put this together I
think that I just really I just want to
put something beautiful out to the world
I didn't want to let any negativity in I
wanted to just and you know I didn't
want to put any negativity out I wanted
to to just really there's enough rotten
stuff happening in the world that I
thought you know what I'm so blessed to
be able to do what I do I love what I do
so I don't want to workout it I want to
I want to go in the studio with people
that I love people that are my family my
friends people like David Foster yeah my
musicians and my co-writers Allen Chang
and and I want I want I kept saying this
over and over again I kept telling my
manager I just I want it to be bliss and
he would call me and say is it blessed
or you have it bliss and I would and I
would say to him yeah actually I it is
pure joy and I think more than anything
I I tried to to really have purpose and
not not allow things to be
results-driven I wanted things to be
organic and natural and beautiful and I
wanted to make a really a baby-makin
yeah romantic old school record yeah and
you did thank you so you have to thank
David Foster thank you Dave Foster right
yeah you have to feel free in order to
be able to make that record I'm sure
there are times in your life of where
you have not felt free when you sat down
to make an album yeah I think that um I
think that it's funny I used to I think
that when I started and I got signed I
couldn't believe that people were I was
doing it you know and um but I also felt
like I was earning the trust of an
audience especially considering that I
was minoan my artistically I'm it was
very strange for me a lot of my life or
my life as an artist because I was
always there was this
sort of strange line that I I would
always listen I was writing songs that
were pop songs that were pop hits on the
radio I was you know and then but I but
my passion and my I think my soul was
sitting in the land of the Great
American Songbook and standards and yeah
and so I think I struggled it with my
identity
sure and knowing like I knew who I was I
knew where the the organic you know love
was coming from but putting it out there
when people even know on an airplane
somebody would you know saying what do
you do for a living right so ominous I'm
a singer you know and they'd say well
what kind of music and I would go you
know I didn't know how to answer I would
say I guess I'm like a disposable pop
jazz guy but I you know so I'm so coming
to this record I think I'm so protective
of the genre I'm so I so loved the the
the music I stand on the shoulder of
giants and the shoulders of giants and
Tony Bennett and then Sinatra and Nicole
and and I take it so seriously and I
think instead of I feeling like I've
earned the respect of the world I feel
more that I've I've earned my own sense
of trust in knowing that I have so much
love for this that I can do it in an
authentic way talk to me about love
because it seems to be as you said what
a lot of people need right now yeah
what's your relationship with love I
thought about it this morning yeah yeah
I thought that that I was you know my
kids were picking out my socks and my
wife was screaming at me because I had
left my stuff all over and I was sitting
in the mirror knowing I was going to
come and do these interviews and I was
like you know trying to just Center
myself and go like Mike what do you want
to say you know and it's funny because I
actually thought of this what you just
said and
I don't think that there this is a
moment where I felt the world needs love
I think I have come to the realization
that we just always do yeah and you know
things can be better and things can be
worse but I have been given this
wonderful opportunity in my life to
twelve to to be kind yeah and to be
empathetic and to have gone through hard
things and to know that other people are
going through hard things and to be able
to to bring joy and peace and healing
and I I think I used to UM I think I
used to be insecure about maybe people
being cynical about those things in me
or the way that I had a certain sense of
childlike wonderment when I looked to
the world you know the fact that I love
Christmas I genuinely love the kindness
that comes from the spirit of that that
holiday and on all of those things and
love songs and romance and I used to
think that maybe that there was a
softness there or some kind of weakness
and and I realized that my business
isn't to worry about how the cynical
people feel about that my my my joy in
life is to embrace that now and to just
and you just put it out there
I might have changed people's lives like
that you do you change a lot you have a
lot of power you mentioned it earlier
getting ready this morning how loud is
your house it is it is crazy I've got
the beautiful four month old baby who is
she running it yet no and she sees this
happy little little God little fat
little beautiful little healthy little
gorgeous yeah but she wants boobs a lot
yeah and and then I've got two little
boys I got Eli was three and I was five
and they just beat the [ __ ] out of each
other yeah that's what you want though
of course that's what I want but it's
really I spend all day and every day in
like this weird zombie movie saying the
same thing over going no don't no no no
I said don't grab that
oh that's literally I I joke about it
but I think that's the lawyers part of
you when you when you you have this
dream of becoming a parent and you think
it's almost like gains Game of Thrones
or something and you think that you're
gonna create these beautiful little
people and you will rule them and you
will be there and then you realize that
it's you are you are not the ruler yeah
it's like you're more like a prison I
will say that so because I have an eight
and a half year old and the one thing
that I girl or girl Wow oh you're a
tackle girl yeah thanks the one thing
that you realize early on is that you
recognize when one of your kids needs a
win yeah on that day and you as a dad
this thing happens that you didn't know
you had in you where you want to make
sure they get a win that day what do you
do on those days to make sure your kid
gets a win on a day when they need a win
you know it's crazy I feel like this is
I feel like my kids actually helped me I
was gonna say a win on the days when you
need to win what and they know yes and
more and more I'm so open to literally
allowing them to see my weakness yeah
you know what I mean I think I think I'm
I'm really gifting my children something
when I admit to them that I'm not
feeling strong or that I'm I'm insecure
I'm scared and there's a you give a lot
of power to a little person when you
look at them and you say that this
person that they see this big big puppy
you know this strong you know perfect
isn't perfect and isn't always strong
and you give them the power to know that
they can pray for you or that they can
talk to you and help you and counsel you
and and I do I come right I mean if I
have to do something scary I literally
will look at both my boys and I did this
morning you know hey boys you know
puppy's got to go out and and I want to
be real and I want to be real to myself
and I want to be real with my friends
yeah can you guys you know give me the
power you know and both of them go like
okay poppy you don't go and do it and I
think I think there's great power in
that for it honestly for me it's yeah
it's what I couldn't ask for a better
pump up to to leave the door and feel
like you know I've got my stuff together